[Music]
delighted to talk to you today thank you
for coming all the way out here I've
been looking forward to this for a very
long time before we get into anything I
got a no you got to explain to me what's
going on with this purity ring thing
melting down these purity rings yeah and
making a golden vagina sculpture it's
nautical what is justice say it's not
gold and people start visiting out about
that
oh why that part of it oh because of the
story where people melted their jewelry
into a golden calf and worship so I was
thinking more swords into plowshares you
know just another Bible verse where you
take something that was meant for harm
and you repurpose it into something
healing for the community so I mean
purity ring's for this thing it was
really big and what's called the purity
culture where girls were asked to sort
of sign a card pledging that they would
not have sex before marriage and then
they'd put a ring on their finger which
was called a purity ring which was this
indication that she was not available to
have sex with until her wedding night
and this would happen to girls and when
they were quite young you know before
they knew really what sex was or who
they were or what they wanted and the
message was and quite often they'd be
asked to get dressed up and their dad
would bring them flowers and their dad
would put the ring on their finger I was
creepy as [ __ ] they're like 11 years old
do you know what I mean it's not right
and so the message basically is that
your body isn't really your own it it's
like sort of the property of your father
and your father's religion it's the
property of the church and though it's
the property of your husband correct and
we must maintain the purity of this
that's right and so I was raised to
believe that was told very directly that
you have to dress modestly because you
don't want to tempt the boys because and
this was a direct message boys can't
help their sexual impulses and so one
boys you have to make sure you don't
ever arouse them sexually because once
they're aroused a certain point then
they can't help themselves
so purity culture equals rape culture
these these two things are deeply
related and so I just know so many women
were wore these purity ring's and we're
basically told to disconnect from their
own sexuality from their own sensuality
from any sort of erotic impulse they
might have and their sexual development
was sort of absconded with by religion
and then later in life even if they
reject those teachings they have a hard
time connecting to their bodies and to
their own desires and so I just thought
you know so many women have these purity
ring's I'm so sorry so many women have
these purity ring's sitting around and I
was like how do we repurpose them what
do we do with them and so I was on stage
at the makers event last year
and was talking to the group about how I
had this dream I had just finished
writing shameless and I had this dream
to get women to mail me their purity
ring's so we can melt them down into a
sculpture of a vagina and I saw Gloria
Steinem was sitting in the front row and
I just said Gloria I I'd like to give
you the metal vagina that's made out of
melted down purity ring's I was like a
thank-you gift from of us all and she
was like I would like to have that
that's like music to her ear all right
so now I'm on the hawk right so
literally day after tomorrow
this sculpture has been made this woman
who makes my jewelry this artist Nancy
Anderson for those that are listening
that's the most badass belt buckle I've
ever seen sweet bird studio and she is
she made a sculpture out of it and it's
and she took some of the rings that
couldn't be melted down so they were of
a different metal and she pounded them
into the word freedom it's beautiful and
we are giving it at this year's makers
conference on stage we will be unveiling
it and presenting it to Gloria Steinem
every next you can't script that that's
unbelievable a dream come true
this needs to become an annual award
though right he's an institutional has
been swiped a golden vagina
or every year at the makers I am I'm
totally gonna pitch that yeah all right
good
you should how many rings did you get
sent we got it like a hundred 70 rings
uh-huh and the notes were devastating I
mean the notes were like melted down it
only brought me misery and one one woman
sent in her wedding band that had a
diamond and said I traded in my purity
ring for this ring because the church
told me it was God's will and yet it
just caused me suffering until I got
divorced 18 years later please destroy
it I mean it was just how it was
diabolical well and I got a lot of
blowback actually a lot of people are I
maybe I'm naive I just had no idea
people would be so upset about the
vagina thing but they're upset on
different levels so a bunch of
conservatives were were just horrified
because they thought it was idolatry and
then other people were horrified because
even women who follow me were like I'm
sorry but that's vile I'm like oh yeah
how deeply have you absorbed the
messages of the patriarchy that you
think that female anatomy is vile like
it just it was hard to even read that
and then there were the really helpful
women who corrected me and said actually
I think you mean vulva vagina is the
canal inside I'm like [ __ ] I know my
anatomy but I'm just saying that's
considered the vaginal image you know so
is that practice still going on oh yes
it's not as big as it used to be there
was a book written by this man named
Joshua Harris called True Love Waits
which actually encouraged people to not
even date to not even do more than just
hold hands to be that pure and he is on
a bit of an apology tour right now to be
understand this man this book that he
wrote infected an entire generation of
people and he was when he penned this
book 21 wisdom pact years old
it went his thoughts were what
influenced all of these of angelica's
for an entire generation and now he's
seeing the harm that it didn't he he
feels badly
actually and but the impulse towards
purity is one that we see in so many
different settings because on some level
we love nothing more than to know who
we're better than and so purity and the
desire for purity shows up in political
ideology it shows up in like how how
paleo are you really eating you know
like yeah it's gonna say it definitely
manifests itself in the health and
wellness space this idea that if you're
gonna eat yourself to enlightenment or
or not eat yourself to enlightenment
yeah that purification of the physical
corpus is a route to you know a greater
spiritual awareness yeah yeah well it's
distinction between purity and holiness
which is something that you talk talking
about yeah because the difference is
that holiness is about connection to
like moments of holiness or about being
deeply connected to yourself or to the
moment or to the divine or to another
person to me holiness is always about
connection to and purity is always about
separation from it's like separating
ourselves from our desires but more than
that separating ourselves from the
people who are impure and so holiness is
about connection to and purity is about
separation from but we pretend they're
interchangeable because purity is just
easier to regulate than holiness
well purity speaks to your inherent
ability to control yourself
right like holiness has to do with
things that are out of your control it's
a good way to put it I mean like and I
think for people you know speaking as
you know somebody who's also in recovery
like yourself you know control issues
are a big part of my you know map of
character defect sense of you know what
the emotional landscape of of relief
that you get when you are controlling
something that you
within your domain hmm and it gives you
a sense of safety yeah and so you have I
think damaged or or people who have
survived some level of trauma and that
kind of ascent to purity or that like
mountain that you're climbing towards
that gives people a true north right
that they're not even aware is leading
them in a direction away from that which
they're truly seeking but it's it's also
just a way to feel like we have the ball
in our own Court exactly and so this is
why I mean I thing I've written about
more than anything and spoken about more
than anything in my career is the idea
of grace and grace is a really difficult
thing for us because it means it
inherently means the ball is not in our
court you can't earn it it's not
something that you climb toward it's
something that you get and on some level
we think it must if it's free it must be
worthless and so I think that people
instead of focusing on grace like to
focus on being good and but being good
has never set me free in the way that
truth has and things that have
interrupted me from outside of me so
well I think good or the pursuit of
being good is the thing that provokes
the feelings of less than and shame and
guilt and insecurity whereas grace is
permissive right that grace is also
something that you describe as being a
pain in the ass from time to time like
it's inconvenient for sure especially so
explain when it's when the reason grace
is tricky is because I want to feel like
I've made myself worthy of something and
if it's truly grace it means it has
nothing to do with worthiness it just is
and that's hard and then also grace
sucks because if it's if it's true for
me it means it also is true for the
people who have hurt me right and I
don't like definitely
don't like that right and like I'm all
for it until we get to that that's why I
always say that like with my luck I'll
be seated at the heavenly banquet
between like Ann Coulter and some racist
cop yeah you believe in grace it's like
super uncomfortable in that way because
because self-righteousness is just never
an option and I love self-righteousness
like I love chocolate and sounds
intoxicating it is but some purity plays
right into that uh-huh knows if you can
really can really feel like you're more
pure than your fellow person
yeah not just your right on your bully
pulpit to be self-righteous yeah totally
well that's why it was that that moment
was so interesting when I was
interviewing Lance Armstrong I had that
conversation with Lance Armstrong on
stage at Target because that day it was
so interesting when people knew I was
the one I so I'm super I'm I'm like
obsessed with the idea of compassion
right now but not like as a virtue to
adopt to be good [ __ ] that nothing's
ever worked like that for me I'm not
like if someone's like oh did you read
that that really great book about
compassion I'd be like yeah not
interested
but I'm so because I'm such a pragmatist
I'm super interested in the effect of
compassion that I'm interested in
because when somebody's been in a true
space of compassion right across from me
it's moved the needle for me in terms of
considering something I hadn't
considered on my own seeing away I might
have been wrong like it's a safe and
it's a loose place to consider those
things whereas when someone's been
accusatory or challenging or calling me
out I immediately get defensive or I
hear it right so I'm just obsessed with
this idea of what's the effect of
compassion on me or even on my body in
conversations and so this person I know
who does trauma work they work with
people in trauma I was asking them like
how do you how in the world do you
manage to not be completely depleted all
the time taking in these stories mm-hmm
and she had this image I just can't get
over which is she said I imagine the
heart of God like right behind my heart
so that whatever that person is saying I
feel it genuinely because it comes
through my heart but it doesn't land
there it lands in the heart of God so
and then anything that comes out of me
towards them doesn't originate from my
own resources and deplete me it rigea
nades from the heart of God it just
comes through me right well that's a
very like unique and specific way of
imagining healthy boundaries for
yourself right right right
okay so that day when people knew I was
the one having a conversation with Lance
they um they said hey don't let him off
easy like people come up to me all day
and be like well when it comes to Lance
everyone's gonna have an opinion or some
advice wait okay but like why right so
what is the endgame because we love to
know who were better than right we're
obsessed with it so if somebody so
obviously had a fall from grace there's
the scapegoating instinct in the human
being is almost inescapable this is why
like when Brian Williams you know when
his career had that huge bump because he
didn't actually falsify a news account
he exaggerated a personal story which by
the way we all have done and every
single time we do it it creates an icky
feeling in us and those icky feelings
build up and we have to do something
with them so what do we do we wait until
someone like Brian Williams comes along
and we just throw all of our icky [ __ ]
that we don't want to tell anyone on to
them and then we have to kill them right
it's this collective way of relieving
the anxiety we think that's gonna make
us feel better that's right but actually
it's like empty calories it completely
is
I mean self-righteousness I always say
feels good for a minute but only in a
way that peeing your pants feels warm
for a minute you know then you smell bad
it's called okay so I'm having this
conversation with plants and I and I
just hold on let me just say one thing I
got I don't want to interrupt you but
like this was my first exposure to you
and everybody needs to know like you're
all right so Nadia's gonna interview
Lance and it's in the round at this very
cool event called the
Tucker project and your opening line
yeah okay you are okay so I once feel
okay this is where I'm going all right
so just so you know they had asked me
Nadia would you so I'm really interested
in compassion right now I'm only really
experimenting with it I don't want
anybody to be impressed like I am just
I'm dabbling in compassion okay so but
I'm thinking about it a lot and they
said would you have a conversation on
stage with Lance Armstrong and I said
yeah I totally would right
then they said would you have a
conversation on stage with Sean Spicer
and I said no [ __ ] that guy just to say
my my ability to be open in compassion
yeah [ __ ] limited okay so I I get to
that day everyone's like give him a hard
time and I sit there and I have that
image of compassion of having God's
heart behind mine and and sort of being
open to this human being across from me
as a person with a unique story and that
most of which none of us know right most
of us don't really know this human
beings full story and and I said to him
opening thing I said was Lance I see
from my notes that you took drugs you
weren't supposed to and then you lied
about it and then I said oh my god I did
that [ __ ] so many times it was so great
and every long did it take you to figure
that line out it was just that day I was
like always this gonna happen and so
just broke the ice
totally and everybody there was like
this shell verse there's a catharsis not
just with him the whole I don't know if
you remember I said you raise your hand
audience if you at any point in your
life took drugs you weren't supposed to
enlightened people like yeah I did that
[ __ ] you know yeah but there's also a
lot of yeah but correct I got that again
it's tricky with Lance you know I see
the grey and I've interviewed him for
this podcast and I got the same thing
like art you know you weren't hard
enough you were too hard everything I
mean everybody's got an opinion on this
guy and my
agenda was I want to understand this
person better who's on the receiving end
of you know a lot of criticism and a lot
of celebratory Pat's on the back like
how confusing for a human being and how
many people on planet Earth have been as
high as he has gone as low and that's
inherently fascinating completely
incredibly human to explore that yeah I
just I really liked him and we had this
rapport that we developed the day before
and and just kind of I I really like I'm
like look dude I know you're an atheist
but you need it pastor you know so it's
just like I'm this person's pastor on
stage and he had a friend there known
him for 18 years and seen him
interviewed a million times she's like
yeah you he was different you know it
was I truly was I felt compassion for
him truly it wasn't I didn't put it on
and so now I'm just interested in that
the effect that that heads but I'm also
interested in like what is it that
people wanted and why why do they want
you to be tough on him what is the need
within us to do you know day me yeah
because like Lance Armstrong has never
done [ __ ] to me as an individual right
nothing he's never done anything to me
so why would I need you know some
catharsis by hearing him say something I
feel so weird
what is the seat of that in your mind
it's that thing of we love to know who
we're better than and in some way it
keeps us from having to do our own work
and look at our own stuff when we can
point to somebody who's worse yeah we
love that well you have an interesting
perspective to bring it back to the
purity ring's with the community of
women who propagated this you know
philosophy for generations when you went
back and looked at your own like
journals when you were a young person in
a very conservative church right yeah
yeah yeah it was interesting because so
people who are raised in really
conservative
settings that we're ultimately the thing
it has in common is that it just gives
you extremely dualistic thinking so
you're raised in this sort of construct
of there's good or bad you're right or
wrong you're in you're out or us or them
saved or lost and so we're seeing that
more than ever right now for sure
and so the but that man when when that's
where you stay in spirituality and
religion
that's the beginner course man that's
like just developmentally that's the
beginner course but so many people are
stuck there and so I was given that
construct of like good or bad right or
wrong and dualism so you can take the
girl out of fundamentalism but it's much
harder to take the fundamentalism out of
the girl because when I left I just
replaced it with really radical leftist
politics and ideologically it was just
very similar in terms of so dual the
stinging there's no gray you know and so
what I realized is the anger I had about
that religious upbringing dissipated and
I felt like I was free and something was
sort of almost healed inside of me when
I was able to look back at that
religious upbringing that gave me
dualistic thinking and not view the
upbringing dualistic aliy when I was
able to look back at it and admit there
were things that were beautiful and
saying that didn't feel like a betrayal
of that little girl who was hurt that's
when I was free in other words
transcending this either-or mentality
yeah black or white yeah binary
perspective and moving towards both and
totally so when I guess two things can
be simultaneously happening yep so when
I could go over their subtlety here
there's good and bad in the religious
upbringing that gave me dualistic
thinking that was the magic that was the
point and we're so reticent to to do
that I think to see to admit there was
something good in something that hurt us
because it feels like it's a betrayal of
the part
of us that was hurt yeah and to bring it
to the to the purity ring's and like
this journal that you had it was this
idea that the purity movement is so
inherently regressive and and awful and
we can wince at it now and yet at the
same time to recognize that these women
were trying to help younger women find
their place within a community that
wasn't really recognizing them totally
so it was this Christian charm class
that I that me and the other 11 12
year-old girls 13 year old girls went to
every week I assumed just by spending
time with me that the fact that I was in
a girl's Christian charm class it
[ __ ] shows doesn't it it does yeah
it's tough you're still reacting against
that no man I'm charming as [ __ ] so it
worked but but so I found the old
workbook including this like how
feminine are you quiz which I included
in my book and I scored very low and and
I was looking at this ridiculous
workbook and across from the how
feminine are you quiz was a Bible
reading verse chart and a calorie
counting chart I mean this is precious
right and so but I looked back with on
it with this blend of sort of anger and
tenderness because these women who were
teaching this class is like man if this
is the only currency if your femininity
is the only currency that you have to
broker anything with in this subculture
there was something very sweet about the
fact that these women were trying to
help us make the best of it
yeah and that's the end that's the end
yeah yeah it's beautiful to be able to
inhabit both of those ideas recognize
them and allow them to live you know in
their own space amongst each other and I
think that's relevant to you know how
you approach someone like Lance mm-hmm
you know how can you have compassion for
him I have compassion for him I'm not
him I don't I don't presuppose to
understand what it's like to be that
person and be faced with those choices
and I think
people that judge that without you know
and have you know walking a mile in his
shoes so to speak it's just it's not
fair this is why I'm so committed to an
idea within Christianity that most
people really recoil from and I
understand why they do but it actually
is the idea of human sin because I think
that that word has been conflated with
like immorality in a way that I find
unhelpful but when I use it there's a
guy named Francis buffered who wrote a
book called an unapologetic and I read
it once a year and he wanted to use that
concept of human sin but he knew that
the term that word was problematic and
so every time in his book that that's
what he meant he substituted this the
human propensity to [ __ ] things up I'm
like okay who's gonna be like I don't
doubt that you know what I mean so the
fact that there is some inherent flaw in
the human which is the reason that
simians all a theologian says the system
keeps throwing up errors you know like
we all have this human propensity to
[ __ ] things up and one of the things
that I've found like I've been doing
more and more speaking in like the
Wellness community and for some reason
I'm in that scene now that well I feel
like the transformation that's offered
in these subcultures is Israel but I
think we'll always be limited if it
bypasses the darker aspects of being
human because the way in which like one
of the places we do see the true
transformation of the human heart is in
like the rooms of Alcoholics Anonymous
and you know what the twelve steps takes
very seriously is the human propensity
to [ __ ] things right it does not bypass
that no it not only does it recognize it
it embraces it yeah completely and
without judgment I mean that's
fundamental to the whole it's your it's
the basis of belonging to that community
yeah and so your your particular breed
of Luth
but Lutheranism is to accept sin as part
and parcel of the human condition but
you're really kind of reclaiming what
that means and translating it in a way
that's different from perhaps our
conventional notions of what it is to be
a sinner or to sin yeah I told it I mean
I in Latin I have tattooed on my wrist
similar used to set piccata which means
simultaneously Center in st. we're all a
hundred percent of both all the time
nobody's like 8020 so it sort of
deflates these really lofty notions of
purity in a sense to go we're always
going to be a mix of these two things
and so what that helps do is that you're
actually never surprised do you know
what you're not going to be surprised if
a human being does something awful and
you're not gonna be surprised if a human
being does something beautiful right
right I will never be an idealist
I couldn't possibly be an idealist about
any human project but I'm really
idealistic about God's ability to redeem
the human propensity to [ __ ] things up
like we can be the people who [ __ ]
things up and something beautiful can
still happen out of it I'm like whoa
like that's the these are the moments of
faith that I have but you could be
idealistic about holding space for
somebody to step into you know a better
more fully expressed version of
themselves right I mean that's kind of
what yeah what you're doing with the
church like there's some Christians with
traditions that believe in like
Christian perfection and like
progressive sanctification I could never
buy into it
ever ever ever but I think we do we do
get the opportunity to grow in wisdom
yeah I think we can increase the wisdom
we have in the world and it does not
decrease the fact that we have the
propensity to [ __ ] things up that
doesn't we certainly have that and it's
exactly like a a like you learn in the
rooms to not judge somebody who comes
back from a relapse it's like well of
course he drank we're you know we're
alcoholics like that's what we do the
miracles that we didn't do it today
it's cool come on back any and you learn
empathy and yeah you learn to reserve
judgment and it's given me just this
expansive capacity to love humanity in
all its forms right and without judgment
and I see that reflected in your
congregation yeah I know you're recently
moved away from that but you know over
the last however many years that you
were ten you know they're like that's
the closest thing I've ever seen to a a
Oh 100% that was on purpose because look
people are so much more frequently
speaking honestly like honestly about
their lives and connecting to God into
one another in church basements than in
church sanctuary yeah yeah I never
really thought about that I was like wow
the honesty that's going on in the
basement is incredible it's such a
beautiful thing that this movement has
created to help people heal yeah and
then upstairs right on Sunday there's so
much [ __ ] yeah it's the human
competition extravaganza once again you
know so I yeah I think that I like
people have asked how is being part of a
12-step community influenced you as a
pastor and as a theologian and I'm like
it's impossible to answer that because I
was 22 when I started showing up to
church basements and I'll be 50 in April
so literally my brain hadn't even
finished developing yet and so I learned
how to be it what it meant to be a human
being and a [ __ ] grown-up in those
rooms and what spirituality looked like
and what honestly honesty looked like so
it there's no way for me to tease it
apart what was that and what was
something else
and what about organizationally I mean
when you look at the movement 12-step
movement and how its continued to grow
and expand and you know maintain a level
of integrity with its roots in a world
in which institutions particularly the
church is you know falling on the sword
of its own inherent flawed humanity that
runs it yeah there's something to be
gleaned from that Oh totally totally I
mean I know what we tried with
house for all sinners and saints is that
for instance we we were we said look
we're anti excellence pro participation
that is such a counterintuitive thought
when it comes to organizations I got to
the point where I wouldn't accept
speaking invitations from any
organization that had the word
excellence and its title so the so what
they said they were against excellent
yeah if they were anti-air we go so like
we didn't we never had a five-year plan
we never had a vision statement we never
had a mission statement we were anti
excellence Pro for it like all of the
things that these institutions of
churches think will save them we said no
thanks hmm all the things that the
church consultants are telling churches
they should do and focus on we said
that's not true and and subsequently
you'd be hard-pressed to find a Lutheran
congregation in the United States of
America that has more young adults in it
yeah what's interesting is that you did
it within the construct of of the
organization you didn't just rent a
space and say okay I'm my own church
you're doing it within the construct of
the Lutheran Church
yeah and they totally at some point you
convinced them to be permissive enough
to let you do it in this non-traditional
yeah but you know why because being a
Lutheran is is its foundational II just
a theological identity what is
Lutheranism well it's like you know in
in 1517 this Augustinian monk you know
nailed 95 theses to the door the
Wittenberg Church and was like here are
95 things that I think were [ __ ] up in
with the church and we need to stop as a
way of trying an invitation to a
conversation and that sparked the
Protestant Reformation and ultimately he
was a pastor and he said he saw how the
teachings of the church were harming the
people in his care and he was more loyal
to the people than he was to the
teachings of the church which is what
I'm trying to do in that book but on but
Lutheranism is is very different than
other Christian systematic theologies
and the fact that the focus is grace
it's
on being good it's not on these lofty
ideals of progressive sanctification
it's it's closer honestly to the 12-step
stuff where it's like oh yeah you can't
do this and but God can do for you what
you can't do for yourself and it is the
closest Christian theology to that
notion which is why I was drawn to it
because I'd been sober for some time by
the time I was introduced to Lutheran
theology and it it gave me language for
what I'd already experienced to be true
and so since Lutheranism being Lutheran
as a theological identity I'm a very
Orthodox Lutheran theologian technically
and so because the denomination trusted
me as a theologian they they have never
questioned me as a practitioner there's
something super punk-rock about that
it's almost war punk rock to say I'm
gonna do this within the organization
than it is to like trash the
organization and do your own thing
because that would be a lot easier it's
much nicer person so it's very
convenient for somebody to look at you
and go oh all the tattoos and the potty
mouth and you know it's you strike a
very unique pose and it allows people to
project a whole sensibility now but you
know and it's more it's more complicated
than that because you're this social
progressive but you're also very much a
theological traditionalist don't lay yes
I know so it's like a conundrum you know
what I'm using recently in interviews is
like the in so many ways I'm not the
story because the tattooed foul-mouthed
lady pastor story is interesting for
five minutes and not five minutes it's
you in the door those years ago yeah it
does but the real story is what shifted
culturally in America that's created a
situation under which I'm who people
want to listen to when it comes to
religion that's the question
so in your opinion how do you answer
that question what did shift Authority I
think what authority looks like has
completely changed and in a way that a
lot of institutions make sure you're
talking that a lot of institutions
haven't paid attention to that ship
and I think for a long time we wanted
leaders to be on a pedestal and to be
the sort of example of holy living or
whatever and yet there's a way that all
of the institutions that we have
experienced have sort of disappointed us
because every time we've looked behind
the curtain we've not actually found the
Wizard of Oz we found scared little men
and women pulling levers trying
pretending to be big right well it's a
it's an abuse of trust and a level of
duplicity right that just leads people
further and further away yeah but the
reason we had institutions to begin with
has to do with the Enlightenment really
I mean because in it like in in in the
past what ever had authority was
whatever our grandparents and
great-grandparents had experienced and
trusted to be true that's what authority
was for us you didn't question it and
the reason is because things weren't
shifting very quickly
culturally right you could you could
trust it well things shifted very
quickly like during the Enlightenment
and suddenly we have this like elevation
of human reason and everything sort of
shifted and so what happened and we got
things like penicillin stuff like that
but now we have institutions that were
developed in order to hand over the
goods that the Enlightenment promised us
right and so now you don't trust
anything in the past you can only trust
things that are sort of new and
inventive so what this is where we have
banking we have universities we have
hospitals we have denominations so all
of these institutions were established
after the Enlightenment to deliver on
the goods okay the promises of the
Enlightenment but then what happened as
we end up with like the Vietnam War and
Watergate and clergy sex scandals and
that's where we pull the curtain back
and we go oh these institutions became
more concerned with perpetuating
themselves and protecting themselves
than they were with delivering the thing
they said they were about right and
because they're run by humans yeah
totally that's the big drop
right right right so I think we're in
this weird time right now we're human
where it you know I Esther Perel will
say like so many big decisions were
always decided for us before now you
know that we we weren't there weren't
all of these options on the table and
that now so much weight is weight weighs
on the individual to make big big
decisions that it used to be the either
institutions or your culture or your
religion was deciding for you
and that's a first in human history yeah
I think it's a very recent development
too extremely recent yeah you know I've
heard you talk about like kids growing
up with you know
choose-your-own-adventure or stories
like they have to they have to imagine
that you know the endings of their own
stories now and everything is super
personalized to meet your own unique
agenda and I think there's a there's a
downside to that and I think it plays
out in and ideas around faith which I
know you talk about but also in in kind
of snowflake culture too you know like
everybody's super precious and I think
that tends to alienate us as much as it
does unify us but like it's perming my
specialness right every variety is the
only way that you're allowed to relate
to me and for me to approve of it right
right and you see it with you know you
got tattoos for a long time but like
tattooing is a way of distinguishing
yourself and if you kind of you know
explore that with somebody like hey tell
me about this then it's almost like
offensive so it's like you can't really
win in that conversation
yeah right right yeah yeah I think the
weight the weight of all of these
choices of self-expression and um can
actually kind of create a lot of anxiety
how do I know I'm choosing right or have
I weighed all the options or you know I
mean things we never even had to decide
before so it's something that we we
inherently want to be ruled well i v
benevolent dictator i think i think that
we need load-bearing structures uh-huh
you know
and that's what religion it's very this
is the first time we've had cultures
that weren't religious like in human
history so there was a way in which
religion was a load-bearing structure in
terms of understanding who we were
understanding morality having a symbol
system for for imaging the divine for
marking the year together there's a
function that that religion has played
in in throughout human history that I
feel like even though the institutions
of religion have heard a lot of people I
just think it's just not time to
dispense with that idea entirely and
it's a really recent idea in human
history that you can just choose your
own symbol system that's that's new
well the foundations of religion are are
crumbled you know and there's a there's
a you know a crisis of trust in those
structures and those institutions which
i think is why people are like well i
feel like i can i'm i like to listen to
Nadia well I think it's just because I I
really do try to be very forthcoming
with my shortcomings and with things
I've gotten wrong or should I don't know
you know there's not the curtain someone
yeah there's nothing you're gonna like
find out that's right like at one point
I was like that's also like something
that you learn in in a a totally like
own those flaws and and you know find
the empowerment and the vulnerability
and to not actually have shame about it
I mean that's the thing is like I
believe in the power of grace so
strongly that I have no shame in
admitting why I need it mm-hmm so then
people feel like they can trust what I'm
saying also like self incrimination is
like my go-to rhetorical move and that
allows me to be more horrible to people
because I'm nice to you but you can
connect with you and I've heard you
speak it's very you know it's not just
it's it's a it's a it's a incredible
experience to hear you speak and I can
feel myself connected to a message that
you're putting out there and it makes me
reflect back on my experience as a young
person going to church and just sitting
in these pews thinking what am I doing
here I can't
I understand what they're talking about
I'm falling asleep why is that guy
swinging that rope with the
terrible-smelling he's dressed up not
like I'm an Episcopalian yeah like an
elementary school I just found the whole
thing totally bizarre and I was like she
used about what I was supposed to get
out of it it wasn't that I had it wasn't
that I was traumatized by it I just
didn't understand it and I didn't
understand why everyone felt compelled
to go like I was getting nothing out
worded to any of it in times of crisis
at all not in a in an organizational
structured yeah in a non-denominational
kind of spiritual way yeah you know I
found God in the rooms of Alcoholics
Anonymous and my spiritual growth as as
you know taking me through you know an
exploration of many different types of
faith and and experiences and practices
and teachers and the like and I haven't
settled into one particular perspective
on that but I've learned from all of
them yeah yeah well one thing that
Astaire said I'm just quoting like
smarter women though myself um she said
that that it's easy that the one of the
things that religion offers is that in
times of of crisis and of pain when
we're collapsing there's something to
hold us like like it's easy to come up
with rituals and practices and stuff in
times of birth or weddings but when [ __ ]
hits the fan there's something there to
hold you that there are these sort of
rituals or prayers that have been worn
smooth by generations of the faithful in
a way that can kind of bring us comfort
when you can't just create your own
thing on the spot when you're in a
position of crisis and pain I thought
can that be
can can you have that connection without
the baggage that comes with the incident
that's the question that's literally the
question right now I mean I when I left
Christianity for a decade
I couldn't have anything to do with it I
was you know after I left the church I
was raised in so when people say like
look a lot of us have to leave for for
reasons of self-preservation like I get
that I ever judge it but I think that
there is a path to integrating our
religious upbringing rather than
rejecting that eventually there's that
kind of work that can be done - even if
it's just you know there's this prayer
my grandmother said when I was going to
sleep every night that's still really
meaningful and I'm gonna integrate that
into my life you know that that that's a
part of wellness to me to be able to do
that so I've been just sort of inviting
people into considering what that might
look like and it doesn't have to be a
betrayal of the part of you that needed
to reject it for good reason to say yeah
but it still formed Who I am on some
level and I want to make friends with
that part of me yeah well there is
something timeless about these stories
in the Bible and the truths that are you
know laid within them and that's
something that Rob Bell has helped me a
lot with you know in his effort to kind
of reclaim this art form that is the
sermon and to really get into you know
the history behind the history and the
nuance behind these stories and trying
to divine you know the truths that are
there that are buried within them and
there's something incredibly beautiful
about that totally but I found that I
can enjoy that and explore that without
having to go to a certain location a
certain day of the week sure you know
yeah I love the Bible I mean I I love
the text so much and it's like this
endless endless reservoir of meaning and
every time I just don't really it's
always given it's always handed over the
goods you know and so this idea that it
has
this one meaning for all time that some
old white man decided generations ago is
insane like if you think it's a I think
it's like a living tradition and so
you're gonna see something in the text
today that you hopefully didn't see
yesterday because you've lived one more
day so I feel like it always has
something to offer about human folly
about the nature of the divine whatever
it is like I love the biblical text I'm
interested in how you found your way
back but I think in order to really
understand that like we need to like
understand you need to go to the
beginning a little bit yeah so you grew
up in the Church of Christ yes it was
called so that's a very from what I
understand a very intense yeah it's like
Baptist plus right it's and your parents
were we're pretty hardcore
in this tradition yeah I mean it was
just our whole lives you know I went to
church three times a week for 16 years
yeah and people can oh where is your
experience as a young person going to
church three times a week that's well
you know the thing about anybody's
childhood is you don't know it's weird
until you meet other people and hear
their stories and you're like oh my
mines weird then you know so I didn't
know it was weird I mean and there were
as beautiful things about it there's
something to be said about being raised
in a community and we did sort of carry
each other through difficult times and
celebrate and joyful times together and
and I was just I'm I was so used to
gather like you said showing up in a
location every week with the same people
doing the same thing I was so marked by
that that on some level I've tried to
recreate a healthy version of it my
whole life right so then what leads you
I was gonna use the word astray I don't
know if that's the right word but like
you start exploring drugs and alcohol at
some point like what happened okay so
what happened is that I was really sick
as a kid so I had an autoimmune disorder
and it one of the one of the things that
happened is it caused
fatty tissue to build up behind the
bones in my face so my eyeballs
themselves were pushed forward out of my
head so they bulged really far out of my
face to where my eyelids couldn't close
and you could see a lot of white around
the entire iris so they looked like they
were falling out of my it was very weird
looking and so I had that eye disease
from ages 12 to 16 because they couldn't
do all the surgeries to correct it until
the bones in my face stop growing so
it's like the worst years yeah because a
lot of people when they're in middle
school they think they look like an
insect I literally did and so I think I
just always thought like one of two
things can happen if you have that
experience you can either maybe become
like a diminished person who tries to
disappear or alternately you can go oh
yeah [ __ ] you right and that's what I
did so I had this anger about how I was
treated that I'm really grateful for
because it that anger preserved
something it did protect something in me
that remained unharmed but it ends up if
you mix a lot of drugs and alcohol with
that either it's not the best
combination yeah so you know I started
using I think when I was 15 and then
left the church when I was 16 and yeah
just it ends up like I had that thing
where did you just don't have the off
switch you know mm-hmm
was it drugs alcohol everything like
what was the drug of choice I did a lot
of drugs I did a lot of coke and you
know a bunch of other stuff but um it
never never kicked my ass the way
alcohol did so for whatever reason
alcohol was the thing that if I had won
this switch went off and I could not I
couldn't stop so
that's ultimately the thing that was the
hardest for me yeah but you got sober so
yeah I did get sober young yeah I'm
Sarah was there an intense bottom there
like what brought you into the rooms
it's such a young age well I mean there
were some physical things just like I
had sores on my hands that wouldn't heal
and you know there were like there were
I wasn't well and I didn't have money to
go to treatment and I'd been I was
estranged from my parents because I was
such a [ __ ] and um so I had to kind of
white-knuckle it and the first time I
sat in a meeting I heard there was a
blustery quality to my alcoholism like
to me I was like look at how good I am
at being a sloppy drunk I gave her sub
bravado to it right and I mean that's
part of the disease like romanticizing
yeah fetishizing totally know and then
just surrounding yourself by other
people who are just as bad so you don't
have to notice that you're not doing so
well
so but when I sat in a meeting and I
heard the honesty spoken about what that
really feels like what it's actually
like to live that life I start crying
like they were speaking the truth about
it and I didn't it took a while like I
didn't I didn't I just thought I could
kind of get my [ __ ] together and go back
out there and I thought you know it
would help me maybe figure out how to
not be out of control as much right and
but I wasn't sure I belong there you
know it was one of those things and so I
it was this there was just this one day
and I was at a women's meeting and I was
maybe maybe five days over and really
shaky I mean I am like I couldn't stop
bouncing my Photon you know it was I I
was shaking and my nerves were jangled
and everything my skin felt like the
rough side of velcro and on and there
was this noise from the floor below like
someone had dropped a pan and I jumped
out of my seat but like no one else
moved
and this woman was sharing and this is
when you could smoke in a a meetings and
she's in the middle of sharing and and I
jump out of my seat no one else moves
and like immediately she turned to me
and she went that'll pass so anyway
about prayer I was saying you know like
and there was something about how
immediate she said that that I went oh
[ __ ] she no she's not like that right
she knows exactly what's going on there
was no judgment there was just
recognition and I thought that
combination of no judgment but
recognition and just naming it I just
went oh [ __ ] I I am in the right place
you know and and those like suburban
housewives saved my ass you know so and
that seems like that's that that
ideology kind of informs how you deal
with your congregation right like
recognition without judgment yeah I
guess I hadn't thought of it like that
yeah yeah yeah and state you stayed
sober ever since yeah yeah 27 years yeah
so then you what you're like working in
restaurants and you're doing stand-up
comedy and yeah there's no there's not a
lot of church happening at that point no
not at all I was actually really
involved in like exploring sort of more
goddess stuff and like women's
spirituality because it was there was
such an intense patriarchal
male-dominated thing and the Church of
Christ like I honestly did not hear a
woman pray out loud in a church so I was
27 like you couldn't women couldn't even
be Usher's in the church that I was
raised down so there was I had to bask
in like the female image of God for a
long time to heal something inside me
before I could go back to my own symbol
system and what pulled you back in well
I met my my now it's husband and I'd
never heard of Lutheran's except for I
guess maybe Garrison Keillor like I had
never I didn't know what a Lutheran Hoss
and and he was like really involved in
like Christian social justice and I was
like [ __ ] is that's a thing I think
seemed I'd never heard those two things
go together and so he sort of introduced
me to more progressive form of
Christianity and I was just I was just
fascinated that that even existed and
you know we moved out to California and
I vary but grudgingly started going to
this Lutheran Church that had this gay
pastor and going to this adult
confirmation class at night and just I
just soaked it up I I had no idea that
you could believe those things I none so
it was like the thing I still loved
which was Jesus plus stuff that seemed
just real and genuine and like easy to
believe because I knew already know it
was true like when they said we're
simultaneously Center and saying I'm
like [ __ ] man that that explains a lot
that's super helpful thanks guys and
then what what compels you to go to
Divinity School and welcome a pastor
it's there were two two things the first
time I had that hit of oh I think I have
like quote a calling was when my friend
PJ committed suicide and he was a polka
comic and also in recovery and I had not
been to Divinity School or seminary at
this point but when PJ died our friends
just turned to me and we were like well
you could do the funeral right and just
literally because I was the only
religious person in my friend group the
the only thing that qualified me and I
said okay and it it was like this it was
at the comedy works in downtown Denver
and it was packed and I was giving his
eulogy and I just looked out and there
were all these like academics and comics
and queers and recovering alcoholics and
I just thought oh man ease these people
do not have a posture and then I went
gonna have to be you oh damn you know so
that was my first hit about that like
trying to notice a sense of being called
yeah well I I felt called to be a pastor
to my people not to fit in some box that
the institutional Church has for if
that's a job you want you know what I
mean those are two different things
right like you could minister to these
people in a way that no one else that
you knew could yeah yeah so that meant I
had to start a church from scratch I
there was not one that existed yeah I
wouldn't because no burns let you they
did well I looked around Lutheran Church
of super nice people but like nobody
looked like me my friends aren't hanging
out there I have to culturally commute
from Who I am - who the churches and I
just thought that's exhausting okay so
paint the picture of the church of all
sinners and things well it is really
like you said that weird combination
that I'm like this you know kind of punk
rock girl but also theologically
Orthodox but liberal but you know this
weird the same with that church because
it's really liturgical so we use this
traditional liturgy so it's traditional
but it's not conventional right and so
um we're in the round and all of the
jobs are shared except for the preaching
like just different people do it when
you walk in your ass do you want to lead
part of the liturgy right you could read
the gospel or surf communion or do
whatever just by walking in off the
street we're like hey guess what we
trust you with the holy things just
could you walk to the door and and
there's so many different kinds of
people it's super queer probably a third
of the conversation congregation is
clear
my dad describes it as like high church
at the Star Wars Cantina right and it's
totally acapella so we didn't ever know
anything to feel like a performance and
so we're in the round and it's in its
acapella four-part harmony like it's
like sitting in the middle of a
200-person choir yeah that's why so all
the music comes out of the bodies of the
people who came like that too
that's just so profile right there's a
pure there's a I was gonna say purity
heard there's a there's an honesty or
something elements all about that all
right yeah and and you said something I
thought was really interesting you said
that you need to be deeply rooted in
tradition to disrupt with integrity to
innovate yeah mmhmm yeah so it's this
yeah this weird combination of
respecting these traditions in the same
way in a a it's like well there's the
twelve traditions like like there's all
kinds of insanity happening yeah at a
big a a meeting but there's this
reverence and respect for the tradition
that's right but every group is
autonomous and so they're all different
like every a a group decides what are
the rules of what you know how's the
format going to be what's the vibe do
you know so there's all that freedom but
the the reason there's so much freedom
is there's that load-bearing structure
that's holding it together uh-huh of
tradition and the face of that
load-bearing structure is you mm-hmm and
if you're wearing the collar mm-hmm you
don't always do that you do you do
always well not every so it if I'm it if
I'm leading liturgy like literally
Sunday I preached at the Episcopal
Cathedral in Portland and yeah I had the
collar at a stall at all the whole
shebang and there's a there's a power
and a symbolism and a tradition that's
built into that but there's also you
have to admit like a separation that
occurs as soon as you adorn that there
is that a wait is this person more pious
and I does this person know more than I
this person is in control and what they
say matters more than what is for sure
yeah until you hear me preach and then
you're like oh not she's just like she's
just like I am never the best Christian
in the room ever but yeah but at the
same time I liked it I liked wearing the
collar because the collar represents the
office that I'm holding and so in a way
all of my four balls don't have to be
the last word because I'm just holding
an office
on behalf of the people and they're
allowing me to hold that office and they
want me to hold that office and to be
set apart to do something really
specific on behalf of everyone and in
that way it really worked right mhm you
tell this funny story about what
happened when the church the churches
started out it was like your friends in
your living room and then it was like 40
people or 50 people but then you got
some press in Denver and they're like
The Bridge and Tunnel crowd like it was
the front page of the other post and
when it came out I was texting people
like hey uh where do you buy a paper
it's like I think several of it I don't
know like nobody in my congregation to
read paper but you know who takes the
paper sixty year olds from the suburbs
and that's who caused my congregation to
double in size overnight yeah so
suddenly soccer moms and dads and
Dockers show up to like you know take a
peek at what's going on
yeah and that's that that's a challenge
to your sense of your your ability to
Eman to emanate grace right like this is
challenging your idea of what you
thought and wanted this
it was organization it was horrible
because I just thought you could show up
to any mainline Protestant Church in the
city and see a room full of people who
look just like you like you're messing
up are cool man like yeah it was
horrible
and and then I called a friend and I was
like dude have you had a similar
congregation I was like have you ever
had normal people mess up your church
and we always had this thing about like
we of welcoming the stranger is part of
our values and so right away always
think of welcoming the stranger is
thinking thinking that stranger is the
one who's ostracized but what if that
stranger is the person who's the
mainstream totally person totally he's
like well you guys are great at that if
it's like a transgender kid but
sometimes the stranger looks like your
mom and dad I was like well [ __ ] you and
then so what happened was we had this
meeting because we were going
like I was like we gotta we gotta do
something
and but I had that phone call and it
felt like this divine heart transplant
you know again and I told the group like
hey might I call my friend and he said
this because I thought what the meeting
would be would be all the people who
were there originally would say who they
are and why the church is important and
then the people for whom it wasn't
really for them would like self-select
out like this is my evil plan and that
but then I told on myself at the begin
of the meeting that I had that phone
call and then Asher was like well as the
young transgender kid who was welcomed
into this community I just need to go on
record as saying I'm really glad they're
people who look like my mom and dad here
cuz they love me in a way my mom and dad
can't right now and I was like oh [ __ ]
meeting over so it's like the spiritual
truth all right I'll see you guys Sunday
but now the part of that story that
people don't know is that the very
people had a hard time welcoming just a
year later even so for years now
I cannot imagine it being house for all
sinners and saints without them that
it's impossible for me to imagine the
church without them we're not us without
them and I think that was chapter 14 or
something in the book pass tricks and
there's this couple that are that fit
that description who show up and they're
just the altar there that just the best
volunteers they do so much work they
serve all the time they're incredible
and the first time they showed up to
help do all this cooking for Operation
turkey sandwich they had t-shirts made
that just say chapter 14 yeah and it
makes it even weirder that you have
though that the crowd is diverse in that
way
oh yeah cuz you walk in there like I'm
unclear with all these people have in
common right and that brings it back to
the similarities were they a right yes
it's like that's the only place I've
ever been where you see this
intersection
the most unlikely community of people to
intersect with each other yeah they
shouldn't maybe the way total yeah but
now also it's interesting because
there's such a culture of turn-taking in
that community that even the people who
on the surface seem like the broken ones
you know we don't have the designated
broken people in the community that I
have seen the people who have maybe some
more complicated lives in in a heartbeat
turn and be of service to the really
stable people in a way that only they
can but don't we take turns at being the
broken one hopefully yeah I mean in a
healthy way we do if it's a healthy
ecosystem of a community that's what
should be happening so you founded this
church and you've grew it to prominence
and recently you decided to move on yeah
yeah so why why why is that well because
it was real I started talking about my
departure the first year of the church
so it was super important to me as the
founder to not for that church to not
have founder syndrome so it was
something I had my eye on and I spoke
out loud about from the beginning and so
it was just important to me to leave at
the right time and the fact that I was
able to leave while they still loved me
you know it's like better to leave a
month too early than one day too late
time to think it's part of that victory
because of the ego identification that
takes place like oh I'm the cult leader
here yeah part of it but on it was
because I loved it because I loved that
church and I wanted what was best for it
and I couldn't I couldn't stay for the
wrong reasons you know and so what
happened was the the person who took
over for me we worked side-by-side for
three years so the last three years of
that I was at the church I was part-time
and and Reagan amber and a gay Episcopal
priest was full-time so it was a slow
transition am i right
and now you're touring around talking at
fancy you're getting golden vaginas no
you know early this is the third year I
spoke at the Nantucket project and this
year they were just like you know which
just like would you preach a sermon this
year yeah it was just it was like
limousine liberals and atheist Jews you
know I was like I preached the hell out
of a sermon so it's been it's really fun
being a public theologian and just being
invited into spaces right you get to you
get to just travel to all these
different venues and do what you do as
opposed to being I can find you a
certain space but I ask myself the same
question if I'm speaking at makers or
Nantucket or a wellness conference as if
I'm or if like you know a year and a
half ago I let a day retreat for all of
the bishops in the Church of England
right so all of them I asked myself the
exact same question no matter who I'm in
front of and it's what what is the most
pastoral thing I can say to this group
of people like I have to dig into this
like what is the thing that's hard in
their lives what is unspoken what is
something that is that is that what's a
hurt that this community might share
what is a struggle how can I speak
honestly enough about that to bring some
kind of hope from outside of them into
the space like I ask myself the same
question no matter who I'm speaking to
is how can I be their past or even if
it's for ten minutes and how much you go
into it you get up in and you know
channel the vibe or do you never you
plan this whole thing out right never
channeling the vibe is not gonna be good
for anyone no lazy i well i i i i speak
from a man I mean now we're just having
but I speak from a manuscript and like
my sermons are 1,500 words and I it like
when I was preaching you know every
other week at house it would take about
15 to 20 hours of work to write a 1,500
words
which is like what 10 or 15 minutes 10
yeah Wow
yeah but but when I was a comic I
learned economy of language I mean
that's the one thing you might not know
about that community of comics is that
the highest compliment within that
community is to say have you seen
so-and-so's act and they go no II got
that are they good yeah they're a really
good writer so how they use language is
simplicity of it correct right and you
don't know that a stand-up act is
written in a sense maybe not words on a
paper when it's well done it looks like
it just blows oh no they know every
horse haws between a word they use a
very specific word if they used one
extra word in a bit it wouldn't be as
funny so I don't know how anyone manages
to be a preacher without being a comic
first but the comics get to get get up
in front of crowds and work out their
material over time you don't have that
that opportunity no they aren't writing
a new 10 minutes so let's talk about the
book why sex I mean there's an obvious
answer to that of course but why invest
this amount of time and intention into
writing a book calling for this
Reformation on how we think about sex
it's like really vulnerable sir
I've been doing it on this stage during
the tour but every time I'm like oh so I
so I'm ordained and one of the most
liberal denominations in the country but
I had to sign a document that said when
I was ordained I would be so I would be
faithful in marriage or celibate in
singleness and what I well that was just
or you can be brought up on charges to
be honest and so it's not even our
theology it's like we borrowed it from
the Baptists I'm like can we give it
back to the Baptist so I didn't think
about I was married at the time and I
was married for almost 19 years to a
really really good good man who I
couldn't say something bad about but we
never connected like it just never
happened
so it was we were roommate to co-parent
and so there was no physical or
emotional intimacy in the relationship
and that was really it was so it was
this quiet painful secret I had and I
dealt with it by doing Crossfit five or
six days of meetings like lifting 160
pounds over my head a regular basis and
having you know quarter inch long hair
and whatever but so when we divorced
when we divorced it there was no
acrimony or lawyers and he's found love
he's remarrying and he's very happy but
when I got together with my boyfriend
and connected so intensely
to someone emotionally and sexually it
was so good for me like it would I
describe it as like this exfoliation of
my whole spirit and it was good for my
brain chemistry and my body and at my
heart and like everything just kind of
softened like people who know me for a
long time there I'm a different person
than I was three years ago and um and so
then I had to go on tour though so we
were together for like a week and a half
and then I had to go on this three and a
half week tour in Europe to support the
UK and German edition of my last book so
I had all this stuff swirling in my head
like going oh my god this is amazing and
then I'm like why did the church make me
sign something saying I wouldn't do how
is it better for my church if I'm not
getting laid it's like I understand like
you know don't [ __ ] the flock as a
baseline ethic you know but um I just
was puzzling and my boyfriend is not
Christian he's not part of that
tradition and I texted him I was like I
gotta talk to you right now and so was
like really unwarranted urgency I was
like why do you think the church is
tried to control sex or so long and
without skipping a beat he goes I just
assumed the church saw sex as it's
competent
and then I went I'm writing a book
so flush that out like explain explain
this idea of sex competing with the
church well when he said it it's one of
those moments where I didn't know
exactly what it meant but I knew it was
true and so it was almost like my
exploration of why that thing was
clearly true and I think it's that
there's a trend there can be a
transcendence you know sex can can can
have a almost transcendent quality to it
but also we're seeking to connect deeply
to ourselves into another thing at the
same time and I think that we want yeah
we want transcendence and connection and
employment and wholeness and we can get
that through religion and sight both
things are sort of and so I think that
because there's such a mystery to it
that I think that it's easier to say no
this is a thing that's dangerous that we
have to control and have boundaries in a
really particular way certainly there
aren't very many institutions that have
done more to create the guilt and the
shame and these horrible human emotions
around sex and sexuality that have led
to you know repression and all of the
you know it'll be gotten manifestations
of what it's like to live in that space
and you know religious not alone in that
regard but it's certainly at the top of
the yeah in terms of being well the
difference I mean obviously the culture
gives us really damaging messages and
the commodification of sex and the
desirability like you have to have a
particular type of body to for it to be
worthy of desire all that [ __ ] but that
but the but the culture has never said
that those messages are actually from
God in the way that the church has you
know to say the creator of the universe
is is saying this message and one of the
things I'm saying on my tour is like
look shame like shame has an origin but
in the Garden of Eden story it says that
Adam and Eve were naked and and
unashamed until they listen to a
snake right and so to me that says shame
has an origin and it's not God that um
shame doesn't originate from God's voice
shame originates from voices who say
that they are speaking for God like the
snake dead and that's different yeah it
is interesting I mean obviously there
was a time when human beings walked
around naked and didn't think twice
about it that's correct but it's so
strange when you think about how we're
all hardwired to feel bizarre if not you
know self-conscious if not ashamed to be
naked like what is what would be wrong
with just this is how we are naturally
brought into this world to walk down
Fifth Avenue like why is that not okay
yeah yeah yeah you know but it certainly
isn't yeah
so what happened you know like
deconstructing that how he got to this
place yeah and the role that religion
has played in fomenting that yeah
well I mean that's um I think that
there's a lot of power to be brokered if
you can say that you are speaking for
God and and and saying like I'm on God's
mouthpiece and and I'm going to tell you
how you should be living and how you
should be feeling and where your money
should be going you know I mean Martin
Luther did that right I mean he was he
had some concerns with some of the
fundraising tactics of the Roman
Catholic Church you know that were
hurting his people and it's because the
church was saying hey you can't question
us because we're speaking from God God
wants you to do this you know and it's
always this religious camouflage to say
well it is written or like God wants you
you know when really it has to do with
brokering power and controlling people
and there's a rich history of that in
religion so explain the kind of thesis
of the book and how this plays out so
the thesis of the book is that
if the teachings of the church are
harming people we should rethink those
teachings it's pretty basic like we
should never be more loyal to an idea or
a doctrine or an interpretation of a
Bible verse than we are to people and so
to have this sort of that's that's the
essence of Lutheranism righteous is like
Martin Luther's whole thing exactly what
I mean it's not exactly what he did but
I'm stealing his move I always do I mean
and I also propose an alternate sexual
ethic you know but that's not legalistic
or shaming that allows for difference
and and that is that stealing a move
from Luther again is that when he wrote
the small catechism he was talking about
the ten commandments he's like the Ten
Commandments are more than just avoiding
bad behavior like the fifth commandment
thou shalt not kill that should be a
freebie right like we most it's like the
middle square of the bingo card right
like we can all just cross it feel good
you know at least we know we got one
right you know and he's like hey hey hey
not not so fast that it means we should
love and fear God so that we don't harm
our neighbor in any way but we have a
concern for their well-being and to
support their flourishing so it's not
just the absence of harm it's the
presence of good yeah
actually having to do something as
opposed to avoids just just being super
awesome at like not doing [ __ ] all right
which is what a lot of conservative
Christianity is like it's it's basically
being good at not doing certain things
right some of which are you know human
impulses right I mean sexuality
certainly being totally first and
foremost among those like just being
this machine that's constantly
repressing right right right well that's
when that's when religion is is nothing
but a reward and Punishment program
yeah I'm dualistic thinking within
religion it just is basically like you
know God is this angry capricious
bastard who is with a killer
surveillance system like is giving you
reward pellets for good behavior and
little shocks for bad behavior
that is that is a foundational view of
God that a lot of very conservative
Christianity sort of holds well there's
few things that can provoke shame on the
level of sexuality yeah totally
totally but those message but to sort of
dig in and go where'd that even come
from I spent two years interviewing my
parishioners and just saying like what
message did you receive from the church
about sex in the body and then how did
that message affect you and how have you
navigated your adult life and I was
surprised how many people were just
immediately willing to share those
stories people want to get free from
this stuff they really want to get free
and so there was a willingness there
that I was shocked by nicely so what are
some of the more notable examples of
that of the stories yeah oh yeah I mean
they're like there are you know young
married couples who did everything the
church said and waited to have sex till
their wedding night so they're told
their whole lives that sex is sort of
dangerous and sinful and you know you
have to keep it at bay but they finally
get married they could not flip a switch
in their brain in their bodies on their
wedding night and suddenly go to having
sex be joyful and natural and
life-giving right and really have a lot
of struggles because of that in the
church they sell in this package deal
they're like if you wait the sex will be
awesome and there you have no language
for it or experience or you know you're
left trying to connect frayed wires
suddenly you know you or gay men who
never reported the sexual assault they
experienced in church because the church
told them being gay was a sin or women
who experienced marital rape when they
were 20 years old and when they told
their church the church because there's
a verse in the Bible that says women are
to be subject to their husbands there's
no way it could have been rape I mean
it's not hard to draw a direct line
right so how do we move past all this
well there's this thing about just
[ __ ] saying the things out loud in
just
super basic way that is an amazing
starting point because then when things
are brought into the light and into
oxygen they have a chance to heal which
they never will win their secret and so
light light even just the smallest
amount of light can scatter darkness
right but darkness has no effect on
light and so to be able to just say the
things out loud is in itself healing and
to hear other people's stories and to go
oh my god one yeah just that is healing
you know this is back to a a like I have
nothing to offer the world except for
regurgitating yeah hey and you know is
somebody who wrote a book called
shameless and somebody who's worked very
hard to overcome your own issues you
know to be shameless yourself like you
don't harbor shame about your past
because you've shown the light on it you
know and I under gone a similar process
it's incredibly empowering and I think
when you can then communicate with that
level of honesty and vulnerability what
you went through it gives everybody else
permission totally there's a sigh of
like right relief right and that creates
connection and empathy and that
trajectory forward for their own healing
that's all I've ever done that's my I'm
a one-trick pony because what I want if
I'm gonna do that if I'm gonna say
something like jeez you know what
talking about being a sexless marriage
is not easy you know but the only reason
I definitely when you're the person that
everyone's looking to to be the wiser
ones right and so but there's only one
reason to do it and because when I do it
I found that it creates a space around
me that allows other people to step into
this space and feel a little safer to
admit what that thing is for them and
it's a form of leadership I always call
screw it I'll go first yeah that's it
yeah well it's also sharing your
experience experience for telling people
tell you should do this and be this way
no never which kind of religion is all
about but you know in like ten year
is a pastoring house for all the sinners
and saints I never once told somebody
what they should or shouldn't be doing
in terms of their sex life uh-huh and
having a community a spiritual community
that's based on Grace and on just being
a beloved child of God and on the fact
that yeah you're simultaneously Center
in st. we all [ __ ] up and we can move on
because there's grace for all that when
that's the main message it ends up
people make pretty good decisions for
themselves without the church having to
tell them what those look like I was at
the gym this morning
and I was listening to an interview with
you I had like earbud you're I had an
earbud in like one ear and there were
three guys and they're working out
they're kind of like they're very alpha
you know like jacked up dudes and one
guy says what he says I'm gonna push her
exactly what he said but it was
something like I've got a bullet for
Nancy Pelosi and like my ar-15 is like
on the way and then some other guy like
patted him on the back and said
something similar like affirming that
and this really weird conversations
going on in front of me and like I'm a
progressive liberal but like whether
you're a conservative Republican or a /
good like talking about killing the
Speaker of the House and like being
giddy about that and like your assault
rifle and I was like I was out of my
mind right and I was like you're in my
ear but and you're talking about grace
and like the inconvenience of it and I'm
thinking I wanted to like intervene in
this conversation which is very would be
as an introvert that's not something
that would be natural to me and I was
like how do I what is the where's the
grace here like what am I supposed to do
yeah I know and I end up doing nothing
yeah yeah what I was thinking
I wonder what Nadia would have done here
or what she would have advised well the
thing about both like the grace thing
and the compassion thing which are super
related is they are 100% never my first
impulse ever so my first reaction to
almost everything is [ __ ] you oh so I
but anger still there oh my god it will
never go away so this is where the whole
being like Christian perfection or
progressive sanctification or
enlightenment I'm like I don't buy it
because to me grace for myself and
compassion for myself is is that I don't
get a personality transplant that my
first reaction is always going to be
[ __ ] you and that's okay and I can have
grace for that I almost never stay there
but I almost always start there I just
move really quickly to something else
now and so if I were to judge myself on
oh my god I can't believe that was my
first reaction again self-flagellation
you know repression double down on my
efforts wasted right it's okay like I'm
always gonna have a little thing about
booze you know it's not but that you get
the reprieve you know you get a
neutrality to it but it doesn't go away
and so same with whatever our defects
are that I'll always have that as my
defect and it's okay and it's helped me
at certain times in my life so my first
impulse is never how do I extend grace
to this person but I often will
eventually get there and it feels so
different in my body my reaction to
things and my response to things feel
different in my body so my reaction to
that [ __ ] you
everything's tense I guard myself I feel
stuff you know it feels different but
when I can do the work and go okay what
would compassion for this person look
like it feels different in my body yeah
and the growth or the evolution is in
the half-life of the reaction before the
more considered response yeah yeah
totally
no okay [ __ ] the [ __ ] you is gonna
happen but that's gonna pass quickly and
I'm gonna get to the more evolved yeah
I'm just this i don't i think it's
unrealistic for me to have some
expectation that my first reaction to
things are is ever going to change so
that first reaction has so much less
power when I'm not fighting it and
judging it when I have made friends with
it and I know it doesn't have to be in
proceed yeah I noticed in the book that
you really kind of restrict your focus
to your own experience and then the
experience of your parishioners or these
people that you interview and you don't
get into you know this the scandals of
the clergy or anything like that so it's
not a broad referendum on sexuality in
the church in general it's more about
how we can have a healthier relationship
whatever wherever you find yourself on
this sexual spectrum yeah it was
important to me to stay in my lane
people are like well did you bring up
the Catholic clergy thing right or what
about Islam and like not my traditions
that's not my story at all
you know why would I it wouldn't be okay
for me to stand above a culture or a
tradition I'm not a part of and critique
it I can critique something from within
my own life and my own experience but I
just have no interest in going outside
that but boy I can't wait to read more
and more about people within other
traditions asking these same questions
and hearing what their answers to am are
well there's something interesting about
the timing also because we're in a
cultural moment right now where there is
discussion and dialogue about the
diversity of sexuality in a way that
I've never experienced you know in my
lifetime seeing all these new variations
you know the duality of male/female yeah
we are like in a way you know 52 like
I'm catching up yeah trying to like
understand what's going on and I find it
fascinating and then you know you're
writing this book and we're seeing these
changes in culture and in religion like
why now like why do you think why is
this the moment
hmm
I don't know but I did I did write a
piece for The Washington Post last
spring about how it feels apocalyptic
because the word apocalypse means
revealing just means to see what's
underneath you know and then it's a big
revealing of what's been going on for a
long time you know sexual harassment is
just a ubiquitous experience in women's
lives that we have been socialized to
de-escalate and to deal with and so the
fact that we're going hey guess what
this has been happening for a long time
we all share this experience is just
revealing what's already there and we
have to keep going we have to I mean we
have to dig in and do that work to say
what's just the truth about this you
know I mean I haven't had nearly as many
horrific experiences as other women in
my life I think I do have the benefit of
having like a really sort of dominant
personality and also I'm a really large
woman so it's a different like six six
one six one yeah about 170 so I have
Nana CrossFit I don't do that anyway you
don't know I only do know it's super
embarrassing I only do yoga like you do
what's up you know I'm single I be like
well these festivals is doing yoga I
know we're talking about compassion and
like being in yoga positions it's super
embarrassing
anyway so the but we all have but I have
all these stories about it too and that
women are socialized for our own safety
and our to try and deescalate situations
so that they don't get worse and what
that ends up looking like for those who
were perpetrators is it looks like we
don't mind and it's not that we don't
mind it's that we're trying to survive
and so I am I'm all I'm here for this
I'm a I'm here for it I understand
there's there there are some some
negative aspects to this moment but for
the most part I think there are a lot of
people who are who who have second
thoughts before they do before they
sexually harass someone you know before
they step over that line and because
they're actually for the first time are
like repercussions right right well
certainly that's happening you know I
think that it's been successful in that
regard and I think it's only gonna
continue and it is it is it's about time
mm-hmm
it's long overdue especially when you
know you get to like in looking at your
book and kind of diving deeper into your
work to see how deeply rooted these
these unhealthy traditions are like how
far back they go and how like entrenched
they are so much so that it can delude
you know an otherwise intelligent person
into you know ascribing to these
traditions just because that's the way
it's always bad but it runs deep I mean
when you're given messages in God's name
those those go down to again are created
place so how is this book being received
by the traditional religious community
is it considered controversial or being
embraced or I just came out I would know
you wouldn't know you don't be all day
attention to that no I mean I have a
thing where I'm seeing I know that there
are people who have read this book this
week and have gone to these book events
who are saying oh my gosh thank you it's
time I'd never felt seen in a church
before I've you know someone's speaking
about my experience I'm here for the
Reformation it's healing I cried the
whole time so the people for whom
because that question I ask before I
speak what's the most pastoral thing I
can say to someone that book is a
pastoral book and so the fact that
people are feeling well pastored by that
book in terms of their own stuff around
sex and religion then the what I was
hoping people would experience when they
read it they are experiencing so to me
it's a success right but then they don't
have a church of all sinners and saints
that they can go to
Sunday well you have their organization
yeah I mean like it's a thing in my
denomination you don't get to go back me
until at least a year
and so I started the church I felt the
most comfortable being in and like I am
also in a place where I'm like where's
my Nadya Bowles whoever wears some huge
tourniquets you know doing all that work
so I can show up you know so I'm I'm
with everyone in the like I don't have a
place to go but so I don't I don't know
what what to do about that because I I
can't start another one that won't
almost killed me but in terms of
refraction I do I do know that both I
try and have clarity about the fact that
both my for lack of a better words like
my fans and my critics these are both
like passionate groups of people who are
equally distant from the truth so the
people who are my fans are just as just
as far from the actual truth of who i am
as my critics are and neither groups are
very reliable sources of information
about myself to myself yeah if you if
you read all you know everything at your
fan say and you choose to believe that
then you have to choose to also believe
all the bad things that's right and you
know what most of the time both the
praise and the criticism of other people
is more about them than me of course its
praises you know so so now that you've
stepped out and you don't have this
affiliation with the organization
anymore how do you navigate like the ego
pitfalls of like being this you know
sort of you know public intellectual at
large
who's speaking about these issues that
are that are very heightened and
emotional for a lot of people like you
become this brand almost right and
there's a lot of trepidation you know
that comes with it yeah well the
antidote for me personally is that my
private life is very small and super
boring
like I don't it's just my I spend my
time alone or with my boyfriend and
sometimes with one of my kids if they're
around and you know I've been doing this
volunteer work in the women's prison
when I can and I go to my a group and I
have a sponsee and I just spend time
cooking and I like there's nothing
there's nothing super cool or
interesting about my private life it's
small and simple yeah and then the
public stuff I do the public stuff and
I'm glad I get to do this like I'm glad
that I'm like a person for a living like
you're a person for a living yes weird
yeah it's awesome if you can get it you
know but but then I just have this
clarity about most of my life is my
private life and that's like not even
interesting at all yeah I do go to my
yoga class I just started a book club in
my yoga studio because I just didn't
know who these people were and I don't
have a church so I'm like I'm actually
really lonely right now I have a
beautiful I'm still with Eric and I have
this gorgeous relationship but my
daughter's in college I rabbit community
yeah she's in college so like I just
like anybody want to just do some you
can't even go to your own church and
like sit no I'd do anything to go I'm
desperate to go it's so you there that's
weird that needs a Reformation why can't
you just show I think it's right they
need to leave them without me for a
while
I know I have to wean themselves off the
not energies it just they're doing it on
their own and it's beautiful and they're
making different kinds of choices maybe
I'm in feeling free and like they're
doing great and I don't want to mess
that up and I wouldn't anyway I wouldn't
get involved literally I just want to be
able to show up to worship everyone well
what is what's Jason Flom doing with the
Church of rock and I'm confused
well I don't know I'm not sure what it
is yet but he just posted on Instagram
the other day like things are happening
something's going on like I wasn't sure
what that meant it's gonna be like in a
couple physical location yeah it's gonna
be a vegan restaurant and a venue and I
I'm like projecting or that you're
involved in that or you are you okay so
I met him at the Nantucket project and I
preached that sermon to the limousine
liberals and the atheist Jews and then
he came up he goes I'm opening a church
this weekend in Vegas yeah it's a pop-up
thing and I'm like who is this guy was
he talking right and then he goes can I
fly you out would you give us a blessing
for the opening and I looked into what
it was and we talked for actually seven
hours that day and um and I said yeah
because I'd liked what it was about and
if somebody wants me to show up as a
clergy person and give them a blessing
it's that's my work to do and so in the
morning I had to do a keynote address at
the National Verger convention at the
Cathedral in Denver sober jurors are the
laypeople who look maybe a little bit
like they're on the faculty of Hogwarts
and they have a stick and they and they
lead they're the they're the ushers for
the clergy and stuff right so they they
lead the procession with the stick of
urge right into the cathedral and they
boss all the clergy around tell them
where to sit which they need that
because we're an undisciplined bunch
right okay so it was the National Verger
convention so the bishop the Episcopal
bishop of Colorado is introducing me and
I'm in the cathedral and I'm addressing
the führer's and I go from there to dia
and fly into Las Vegas and meet Jason
Flom and at the Life is Beautiful
festival they did a pop-up of the Church
of rock and roll and Greta Van Fleet
played right in this tiny venue maybe a
hundred and twenty people half of whom
were deaf or hard of hearing all of us
were equipped with these vests that um
that
oh my Coptic yeah and so on our ankles
and our wrists and we had these vests
and it was hooked into the sound system
it vibrated with the music and so the
hearing the heart of hearing the Deaf
the hearing people were sharing an
experience and at a concert whether you
could hear or not was a pro fad like
that's inclusion you know and in greta
van Flav's playing for like 120 people
and I'd give this blessing and yeah it
was great so I think she's trying to
he's getting funders and gonna have like
actual locations that are venues and
vegan restaurants and it sounds fun yeah
but it's not like a church well to Jason
if you charge it okay well it's the
Church of rock and roll I guess right
and and they have these things that
they're about like like you know all of
this stuff that they believe this it's
like you know be optimistic and be
welcoming and be brave and you know all
of this stuff and I was like hey I
believe in those things and so I'll
bless this thing right it was yeah it'll
be cool to see what he does with that
yeah I agree he said he's a good guy I
mean you spent what he's not on the
board of directors of the Innocence
Project for 25 years that guy is he's
done a lot he's done a lot it's crazy
he's mean he's uber successful in their
music this guy's a legend but his his
work
the wrongly accused is kind of amazing
it's inspiring yeah he's a good guy so
what is it that you want people to take
from shameless like who's it for um it's
for anyone who's felt ashamed of their
sexual nature because of something
someone told them in God's name
you know it's for anyone who's had to
keep their love life secret it's for
anyone who hasn't fully connected to
their own erotic response systems
because of religion you know who have
not experienced flourishing or who have
a gay son and they're like outsiders in
their church now because they support
their kid who's awesome you know I mean
there's so many people out there have
been damaged by the Church's teachings
around that stuff I actually say in the
book like look man if you look around
your life and your church and you only
see like cisgender heterosexual straight
couples who married their one true love
and never masturbate or look at porn and
if only had sex with their partner and
it's still really good and they've had
nice Christian children and like so like
the Church's teachings has it have only
caused flourishing and people are
actually glowing with the satisfaction
of living in quote God's special plan
for Humanity like if that's all you see
in your life and no one's been hurt by
any of this [ __ ] this book is not for
you
the I'm sure those people exist everyone
else yeah you use that example like the
crop circles right there a circular
fades when you're flying in an airplane
you're like why are these round not
square and it's not that they're it's
not that they're round it's just that
the irrigation goes in a circle and
what's outside of that circle doesn't
get fed yeah and the people that don't
fall in there plant it in circles it's
watered in circles and so the the water
doesn't get the center pivot irrigation
system doesn't allow water to get to the
edges and I'm like God planted a lot of
us in the corners and the center pivot
irrigation of the Church's teachings
around sex and bodies and gender doesn't
include us but there's the church and
then there's the teachings and the text
and what's counterintuitive about what
you're saying in the book is that the
answers that you seek or the Reformation
that you're advocating can be found in
returning to the text right right which
is not what you expect you expect like a
big [ __ ] you and we're going to do our
own thing yeah but you know a lot of
times the source of the harm can be the
most potent place for a sealing you know
so I think going back to the text is the
most powerful move you can make yeah
it's gotta be really painful for a lot
of people though just to even gather the
courage or the gumption to even face
this yeah it's these events the past you
know I've done five this week and
they're been you know 500 to 800 people
in each one and are they in churches
yeah it's in churches and I talk about
why I wrote it and I always have another
voice somebody who is mostly people
women of color who have a different
social location to talk about their
experience as well and but we have these
cards that say you know I'm ready to be
shameless about dot dot dot and people
have been filling them in and they're so
powerful I mean everything from I'm
ready to be shameless about like my
aging body
I'm ready to be shameless about how much
weight I gained after I was raped or I
mean it they're intense you read them
out loud like like testing at Nantucket
project where they were reading though
exactly where I got that that's where I
got the idea and I read them out and
then somebody was like I'm ready to be
shameless about having really great sex
after my 79th but so then people feel
left less alone I want them to feel less
alone
and then I wrote this benediction that I
give at the end and then I we just blast
princess kiss and I invite everyone to
dance and they do you can tell that they
want to move like they want to express
the freedom that they're starting to
feel and it's been powerful that's cool
how many more cities do you have to go
all of them no no you just seem totally
on the road yeah no I I go home for a
couple days and then I think I have like
seven or eight more cities yeah well
let's close it down with one with the
world okay what am i doing you're here
to take advantage of that no I wanted to
say I wanted I wanted to like address or
have you say something to the person
who's listening who who doesn't have a
connection with faith or perhaps like
lost their connection with faith in
whatever tradition they find themselves
and like what is it about faith and
connection that that you find to be so
important as part of the human condition
and how can that person find their way
back to a place of of incorporating that
into their life well in a way it's not
like a super popular sentiment but I
just I don't feel like I'm enough in a
sense that I do think having a power
that's more than just me and accessing
that is
has transformed my life in that that's
possible and available for anyone
regardless of what they believe or what
sort of you know faith they have that
that there are things that accessing
like having a connection to our source
and to the divine allows us to undergo a
certain type of healing and
transformation that would be very
difficult for us to do just as our own
on our own as individuals so that's the
power of it to me and and there are
things like people who are raised
religious and had to leave
sometimes they're still like hymns that
are dear to them or prayers their
grandmother sad or whatever and I think
just finding those things and
integrating them back into our lives on
our own terms can be really healing and
it's like this spiritual reclamation
project and and it's okay to do that
it's who you are and it's fine because
your symbol system forms you in a way
that's hard to escape so making friends
with it on your own terms as an adult
can be yeah it could be healing when you
said the word hymns I had a flick up
almost like a visceral physical negative
reaction to that like every yeah like
everything all the trappings around
everything churchy yeah just repels me
interesting love hands okay only if
there aren't it's not like anything
happened to me
yeah it's not like you have some trauma
no it's just like mm-hmm I'm sure I'm
not alone
what's it like was it was it a huge part
of your upbringing or was no not huge I
mean it was all I knew yeah
it wasn't like front and center like you
it was you know we went to I went to
Sunday school and we would go to church
on Sunday and then it was just on you
know kind of occasionally and then it
was holidays but what's interesting as
my parents have found their way back
church there's a church across the
street from home where they live in
Washington DC and that's become really a
super important part there
life and that was not the case when we
were growing trusting well that's all I
knew and um I just never even even when
I wasn't part of it I didn't I could
never pull off being an atheist you know
and uh did you try it you were trying
that well no I just admired it I think
in others and there's this guy Frank
Schaeffer who said this thing hit
Francis Schaeffer a famous of angelical
as his father but Frank said in an
interview I think with Terry Gross she
was asking you know like well you're
after all that like you still are part
of a church aren't you any good yeah I
am and she goes why and he goes look all
I know is that like if what I wanted
more than anything in the world was to
be an atheist all I know to do is to
just pray to God to make me one I that's
like I can't not be this thing on some
level if I wasn't an alcoholic I'd drink
everybody like the same like circular
very good cool well delightful to talk
to you I enjoyed it best of luck with
the book like 85 pages into it so I
still have a ways to go but I'm really
enjoying it and it's important work that
you're doing you know you're really
exposing people and and and opening them
up to ideas around faith and religion
that I think most people haven't been
exposed to myself included so well also
I just I want people to have better sex
it's as simple as that I mean I feel
like it's a pastoral concern of mine
that like I won't good sex man I feel
bad about oh my god absolutely no not
feel bad about you yeah
shame and sex man that's tough my
publisher when I said I'm gonna write
this he goes did you literally scan the
horizon for the biggest giant and you're
like well I'll take that one down right
definitely there's definitely a gorilla
in the room to tackle with this one so
it's cool it's awesome I love everything
you're doing super glad to have had this
time with you so thank you
if people want to
come in here you speak is that I these
are open to the public right yeah
there's only a couple cities that have
tickets left it's mostly sold out but I
think maybe Oh New York City for sure
they're still tickets for New York but
if you go to Nadia Bulls Weber
you have a schedule up there right I
would imagine think so yeah for sure
and at sarcastic Lutheran on Twitter
aster yeah sarcastic Luther yeah yeah
you're pretty easy to find
yeah all right well thank you Thanks see
ya oh wait you're gonna do a prayer no
no I'm good you are I just assumed yeah
yeah is there one in here right around
the corner
[Music]
you